- Welcome, everyone.
We're gonna be talking about scaling AI,
scale trusted AI adoption
with Salesforce and AWS.
My name is Shibani Ahuja and
I am one of your hosts today.
But I'm joined by four
gentlemen, three gentlemen here.
We've got Amit Bangad,
Director of Go-to-Market
Applications from CrowdStrike.
Welcome.
- Hi.
- Hrushi, Principal
Solution Architect from AWS.
And we've got Pravin, who
is the Managing Director
from Deloitte Consulting over here.
So good spread. And I am Shibani.
I work at Salesforce, and I'm
gonna start with a small story
of what my role at Salesforce is.
But before I do,
a love letter from our
lawyer from Salesforce
to say, please make all of
your purchasing decisions
on all of the products that
are readily available today,
not on any future-looking
products that you might see.
Obligated to say that. I try
to say it in a way with love.
Three things we're gonna talk about today.
So, one, the first part
is I'm gonna take you down
a few trends that I've seen of CIOs
and folks that are implementing AI
and this whole notion of
AI and what we've seen in,
what I've seen in the industry
as far as trends have gone along
in the first, I'd say for the last year.
The second one is we're
gonna go a little bit deeper
on this partnership that we
have between Salesforce and AWS
because a lot of folks
ask that question to say,
"Wait, aren't you, are you
competitors? Are you partners?
"How do you partner? I'd love
to learn more about that."
And then the last one is where
it's gonna get a lot of fun
where I'm gonna be able to grill
and interrogate these three
guys on stage over here.
We'll learn more about the
success that CrowdStrike has had
in becoming an agentic enterprise.
We'll also leave open time for Q&A.
So think about all of those really hard,
juicy personal questions
that you wanna ask these
gentlemen over here.
I'll help facilitate that as well.
Okay, so what I'm gonna start
with is a small introduction
of who I am and why on
Earth am I on stage here,
besides the fact that Salesforce
is sponsoring this event
and I happen to work at Salesforce.
Now, a year ago, however, I
was not working at Salesforce,
I was sitting in your seat.
I was working at one of
the largest banks in Canada
and I was driving a massive
technological transformation
thing called personalization.
Also, for a little bit, I was at TD Bank.
And for a portion of time,
I also ran all of digital
for the Canadian Bank.
So I knew a thing or two
about working with Salesforce.
And so what happened was,
part of my remit was the Salesforce stack,
amongst many other technologies,
as we were driving digital
and creating these personalized
experiences for customers.
And Salesforce is notorious
for wanting to put
customer stories on stage,
a little bit like what we're doing here,
where if they've had a
success with a customer,
they invite them to come
up, tell their story.
So I was working at TD Bank,
I got this invite from Salesforce to say,
"Hey, Salesforce has
this internal conference.
It's for Mark Benioff and his top leaders,
like 450 SVP plus will be in the room,
and 73,000 colleagues will be dialing in.
It's like an internal employee thing.
Would you come in and
will you tell your story
about what you drove at TD
with personalization, with Data 360?"
And I said, "Sure, no problem."
And they said, "It's in Hawaii."
And I went, "Oh, if I must."
So off I go, I fly to Hawaii,
and I'm sitting there,
they're asking me questions
about the transformation saying,
"You know, how did you use Data 360?"
All the typical questions
that they would ask
to entice and incentivize
their sales teams.
At the end, I was asked one question,
and that question was,
"Shibani, you've got Mark,
who's sitting as far as
you are in the audience,
you've got his top leadership here,
what advice do you have for them?"
Now, what you'll learn throughout today
is I have zero filter and I let it rip.
Like, I mean, I made it
a standup comedy show.
I said, "You know, you
guys are like a timeshare.
You like set us up with
really, really nice dinners,
but we have to listen to
someone talk about sales
for 45 minutes and maybe we'll
get a nice dinner out of it
and we might get a gift."
And I kind of went on and on and on
about what my experience was.
And I said, "It's ironic
that you're helping me
put my customer at the center
to drive personalization at scale,
yet when I show up for a meeting with you,
you bring 22 people and I have
to know who's Sales Cloud,
who's Marketing Cloud,
who's Service Cloud."
And I went "Like, this is
not how you do business."
And so, you know when you're on a roll
and you know that you should
stop, but you just can't stop?
That was what it felt like.
And so, then I finally
stop and Mark stands up
and he's a towering guy,
and I'm very, very short.
And he shakes my hand and
I get a standing ovation.
I'm like, okay, so I'm
not being escorted out.
This is good news.
As I am walking out of the venue,
someone says, "Watch out.
They're coming for you."
And I think before I
even got back to Toronto,
which is home base for me, I
had gotten the call to say,
"Hey Shibani, you've got a lot of opinions
on how we engage with
the office of the CIO.
And with our shift now to AI
and agentic and autonomous
and Agentforce, you know,
we'd really like your help
in helping us better
understand our customer."
And so now I'm at
Salesforce and I'm leading,
my title is a bit vague,
ultimately, I'm leading
our go-to-market strategy
for how we engage CIOs.
And these are enterprise level CIOs,
because we just don't do it right,
or we hadn't done it right,
and we weren't necessarily
seen as a serious player
in the AI space.
And so we've been doing
a lot of CIO events.
What ended up happening was I joined,
and I do a lot of speaking.
I share all of this
because in the last year,
and I just hit my one year anniversary
on November 18th with Salesforce,
I have met with over 457 enterprise CIOs.
And these are not just hi, shaking hands,
but these are deep conversations
through one-to-many engagement events
where I may be either
meeting with them one-on-one
and helping them, guide
them on their strategy
of where they wanna go,
how they wanna get there.
Or just general education on,
not necessarily products and sales,
but what, this era that we're in.
And the number one insight that I've seen
as we are going through this
technological revolution,
the number one insight
is that AI is the smallest, biggest word.
And what I mean by that
is, I can't tell you
how many conversations
I'm having with CIOs,
or I'll be in a room with tech leaders.
It could be anyone, tech leaders.
And you'll have like the sales team here,
you'll have tech leaders here,
you'll have data folks here,
and everyone is using the word AI.
Everyone.
Good. That's good.
That's the conversation we wanna have.
But if you listen very carefully,
one person may be talking
about predictive AI,
another person talking
about generative AI,
another person thinking they're
talking about agentic AI.
And if you listen to the
words really carefully,
they're literally just
describing generative AI.
And so that was a massive
aha for me to say, like,
I don't know how well
people are being prepared
to think about architectures of the future
if they haven't really paused for a moment
to really fundamentally think
about the architectural differences
between generative AI versus agentic AI.
And then, you know, that study hits,
that MIT study that creates a lot of noise
around 95% of pilots are
failing to deliver value.
Well, that's on generative.
That's not on agentic.
So this is just the setup,
and what's happening,
and so these CIOs are
having these conversations,
they're rushed to try to get
a use case in production.
And now all of a sudden what's happened
is it's not unlike the internet,
or cloud, or even mobile,
the CIO was squarely in charge
and was delivering this
for the organization.
Now, suddenly, with every board member
and every CEO having access to ChatGPT
thinking they are an AI expert,
they're going, "I need a
use case in production.
I need a story to tell my investors.
I need to get something in production."
Their business leaders
are putting this pressure.
Suddenly these leaders
are under immense pressure
to just get a use case in production.
And they're going through
these thoughts that say,
"Should I build, should I buy?
What's the use case that I should get in?"
And one thing that I've
seen in terms of maturity,
and again, in a year,
and this maturity I've only really seen
in the last two to three months,
is as people pause and
recognize the difference
between generative architecture
versus agentic architecture
that would enable a digital agent
to traverse the virtual
halls of your organization,
I'm seeing the shift of build
versus buy conversation,
that also evolve a little bit.
And it's changing from one of,
"Should I build from scratch?"
And I kind of, I would
giggle when someone said,
"I'm gonna build my agentic
architecture from scratch,"
going like, do you really
know what that means?
That's a lot.
So it's shifting from
build to buy, from that,
to now talking about,
should I be going with a SaaS provider?
Should I be going with a
cloud service provider?
And so this has really
been the conversation
of what is it that you're trying to build,
what are you trying to drive?
Understanding the core
differences between predictive,
generative and agentic.
And I'll give a moment 'cause I love it
when I see cameras out to take pictures
and I'll flip the slide as
soon as you've got those.
Okay, good.
It's like popcorn, I wait for
the popcorn to stop popping.
Perfect.
And so now this is giving
rise to another conversation
to say, should I go
with the SaaS provider?
With the SaaS provider,
I can build at scale,
or I can build at speed.
They're gonna provide me templates.
It's gonna be grounded
in my business logic.
So you think about the
Salesforce platform,
we have all of your customer data.
So theoretically, being
able to create agents
that are leveraging your customer data,
it's in a clean spot.
That'll be a fast way to do it.
And they're gonna be
ready-made with guardrails
because Salesforce already
has all the guardrails
that are built within the system.
But then you've got another
cohort of folks that say,
"Well, Salesforce is kind
of like a CRM company.
My COO, my CMO cares about them.
I'm not really gonna look at
Salesforce for agentic agents."
And you've got those that are thinking,
"I'm gonna go with a hyperscaler,
a cloud service provider.
They're gonna give me the
options to choose my models.
Like, I'm gonna be able
to build custom agents
that I really need and want
throughout my organization
and with customer security architecture."
And this is where we're
starting to see more stories,
like the one we're gonna
share with you today,
is there is a world
where both could exist.
And that is a world where you
start to look at partnerships,
the Better Together story
of Amazon, or of AWS,
and Salesforce coming together,
where you can start to
take all of that rich data
that you have on customers,
be able to harmonize that,
create agents that operate with context.
You've got model options.
So again, as a customer, I often thought,
oh, Salesforce is like a
beast. It's a monolith.
They want me to put everything in it.
They want to be at the end-all be-all.
But the reality is, choose your
lake, choose your warehouse,
choose your model, choose your partner.
And so there's been a lot
more of that aha moment
where folks are going,
"I didn't realize that
I could do this and this
to bring it together."
Being able to create a
unified agent strategy,
being able to create these
multi-agent ecosystems
and all with the trusted guardrails
that are extended beyond
just the Salesforce ecosystem
and the AWS ecosystem.
And the partnership
benefits are well beyond
even what you're seeing
just here on slide.
That's really what I wanted to share
and really talking about CrowdStrike,
how CrowdStrike is now
an agentic enterprise
that has taken this leap forward
with both Salesforce and AWS
to start creating these agents
that are gonna operate at scale.
And it's with that partnership
and the Salesforce Agentforce 360 platform
that they've been able
to get context, clarity,
the richness that's necessary,
and the safety and security and guardrails
for those agents to operate at scale.
All right, now chapter two,
I'm gonna hand this off
to Hrushi, my friend.
- Sure.
- Who's gonna tell us and
go a little bit deeper
on that partnership
between AWS and Salesforce.
- Thank you, Shibani.
Good afternoon.
Principal Solutions Architect, AWS,
and I think since the last few months,
I've been working very closely
with the Product and
Engineering Team at Agentforce,
specifically to help guide
on the model optionality
and the agent interoperability
integrations on AWS.
So these are the two key
topics of today's session.
So let's dive in.
Now, before I get into
the further part of it,
I want to bring, first thing is that
for building any agentic enterprise,
you need trusted data
to fuel your AI agents.
And by this time, you must have known,
looking at the Agent 360,
that Agentforce works
on this trusted data,
it runs on this trusted data.
Now, as we have established,
that trusted contextual data is critical
for any agent to work.
The next logical question comes says,
how about giving the
empowerment for the users
to choose their preferred AI models?
When it is like, if you look at an agent,
agent is powered by the
LLMs or the backend models.
So to do that, Salesforce just launched,
I think two months ago,
support for Anthropic Claude
Sonnet model on Bedrock.
This enables the joint
customers, our customers,
to keep the data within the
Salesforce trust boundary.
And this helps actually,
specifically when it comes to
thinking about the
models which we use here.
You will make sure that
the data never leaves
the trusted boundary, right.
Now that we have kind of,
if you look at the various
LLM flexibility we have here
in the Prompt Builder, in
the Atlas Reasoning Engine,
we can select a bunch of
models from the Amazon Bedrock.
So with LLM flexibility,
our customers can now build,
or I would say, rather maximum
control on their security
when building the agentic enterprise.
So now that we talked about
the unified data strategy
or the model choices for
borrowing your AI agents,
now let's think about
taking these digital labels
to the next level,
like coming up with a
unified agent strategy.
And how do you do that?
So this is done through the way,
if you think about Agentforce
now actually supports,
the agent could, say,
multi-agent orchestration,
and multi-agent orchestration is possible
through few things, right.
So one other thing is that
if you, as a customer,
in order to build, you
know, an agentic enterprise
using Salesforce and AWS,
what you have to think about here is that
the Agentforce with MCP client support
can now talk to the MCP
servers provided by AWS
and plus, the AWS MCP servers
are also made available
on the Salesforce AgentExchange,
which helps you to deploy
your agents rapidly
in a production environment, right.
So this way, I mean,
if you look at the other
options which it has,
is the agent-to-agent collaboration.
So agent-to-agent interoperability
is based on Salesforce's,
or you could say Agentforce's,
open agent collaboration,
which is based on the
standard protocol called A2A.
That helps the Salesforce agents
or the agents for agents to
talk to any other agents.
So here, what we have
shown is that you can talk
to an agent sitting on Bedrock Agent Core.
Bedrock Agent Core Runtime
is one of the several
less managed services from AWS
to run and scale your agents.
You can talk to those agents,
or you can talk to any third party agents.
And also, coming up very
recently we can think about
is also the tools which
the other agents can call,
assuming that the Agentforce
agent is as a tool,
so they can call those tools
through the Agent Core Gateway.
That will help you to
route the tool traffic
to the Agentforce agents.
So with that, let me pass it on to Shibani
and to our amazing CrowdStrike customer,
a leading security provider
and an agentic enterprise now.
- Perfect. Thank you.
All right, so this is the part
where we're just gonna
get into conversation.
And I'm short, so I'm gonna like lean up
so you can see me over there.
- Yeah. It slides more.
- Sorry, what was that?
- You can click few slides more.
- Yeah. Yeah.
So we're gonna talk about CrowdStrike.
CrowdStrike is an agentic enterprise.
And to ask and get deeper
into those questions
of how did they become
that agentic enterprise,
what were the aha moments
that they went through
as they were becoming
that agentic enterprise?
And think about the
questions that you have.
I have a couple of questions that I've got
that are warmups.
But this is an opportunity for
you to learn from your peers
and from those that are on the stage,
both from an implementation, a partner,
a platform, SaaS provider, and
our customer's point of view.
The first question that I'm gonna ask you
is not on the script at all.
- Really?
- What's your guilty pleasure?
So, and as you are introducing yourself,
so maybe as you're answering the question,
give a small intro of your role.
- Awesome. Yeah.
- Guilty pleasure. What is it?
- So my guilty pleasure is chocolates.
- Chocolates, okay.
- And dark chocolate specifically.
So I'm totally up for it
anytime during the day,
during the night, so
that's my guilty pleasure.
So briefly introducing about
myself, I'm Amit Bangad,
Director for Go-to Market
Applications at CrowdStrike.
I have been part of CrowdStrike
for close to three years.
I've been part of this
ecosystem of Salesforce
and go-to market systems
for more than 15 years.
At CrowdStrike, currently
I manage that platform
and I'm primarily, in this context,
responsible for building
those high value agents,
which not only bring
operational efficiency,
but also reimagine the
complete end-to-end process
when it comes to agentic enterprise.
- Amazing. Thank you.
Guilty pleasure? Yeah, go for it, Hrushi.
- I think electronic gadgets.
- Electronic gadgets?
- Yes.
- Any in particular?
- Specifically laptops.
- Laptops. Okay.
Do you know as a kid, my Dad and I,
every time Sony would release something,
MP3 player, laser disc,
we'd be the first to get it.
So I get it.
I get that obsession.
- Right? Yeah.
My son was buying a gaming laptop,
so he was thinking about,
"Hey, what's your budget?"
I said, "No, let's, let's
look at the specification
and then think about it."
So that's how I mean, yeah.
But yeah, I mean, I'll introduce myself.
I've been with AWS around six years now,
and I've seen a lot of ML startups
and ISVs I have worked with.
I'm happy to, you know, give my insights
into how things work here,
what questions you have.
Good to understand that
and explain it to you.
- Great.
Pravin, guilty pleasure?
- Okay.
So I was gonna use one
of the guilty pleasures
which was already used,
so I'm gonna switch
to another one that I've got.
I think it's anything and
everything around Indian food.
- Indian food, really?
- Oh yeah.
- So if I-
- That seems so healthy.
- Yeah, I know. Like I-
- I'll give you my guilty pleasure.
I'll tell you how it's done.
- My daughter keeps telling me
that I need to start losing weight
and then how I should not
eat a lot of Indian food.
But as you could imagine,
that's not happening.
- What's your favorite Indian food?
So I know when next time you
come over, what I'm making.
- Yeah, I think my favorite
Indian food is anything
which is spicy and non-vegetarian,
like chicken or goat.
- Got it. Noted.
- Yeah.
So as a quick introduction,
I'm Managing Director in Deloitte.
As part of my role, I primarily focus
on like helping my clients
with like business
transformation engagements,
which are focused on not only just driving
the operational efficiencies,
but like truly driving
like revenue growth for my clients, right.
And as we do that,
I've been working with the
Salesforce plus AWS ecosystem
for the good part of like,
I guess 15, 16 years now.
And prior to that,
I was also working with
the go-to market systems.
I used to help with implementation
around like one of the old
CRM solutions called Siebel,
if you guys have heard about it.
- Mm-hmm.
- And internally at
Deloitte, I also lead our,
what we call as a customer, 360 practice.
And considering like everything around AI
and then everything that we have discussed
about like how data becomes
the fuel and the food for AI,
that has been one of the core areas
that I've been focusing on helping clients
getting on that strong foundation
that can help them scale their AI journey.
- Great. Okay. So my guilty
pleasure, let me tell you
since you all are so innocent.
- Yeah.
- Bourbons and burger.
- Ah.
- So, I'm from Canada,
where if you aren't aware,
there's no more bourbon on our
shelves because of, you know,
for whatever reason there may be.
So every time I cross the border,
I make sure that I get my
share of bourbons and burgers.
- Which brand is your favorite?
- Well, Woodford is good for everyday.
- Woodford.
- Perfect.
- Yeah. For the everyday.
Okay. Now to get into the tough stuff.
Amit, tell us about your team.
Why is AI so important
to your organization?
- Absolutely.
- What are you driving?
- Yep. So I lead a team of
a combination of engineers,
testers, analysts, product
owners, architects.
So that's my team.
But what's really important here is
whom do we support, right?
So we support our business,
internal business teams across
marketing, across sales,
across customer success, legal,
finance, product, et cetera.
Beyond this, we also build tech
solutions for our customers
and partners to use on
their respective portal.
So AI is not only important
for us, it's basically,
it's a foundation of how we
think about our three Ss, right?
So, which is speed,
scalability, as well as...
I mean, speed, scalability, and strategy.
So at its core really,
AI helps us to, A, think
faster, understand faster.
So understanding the customer
behavior, that's one.
Then beyond customer behavior,
the internal inefficiencies, right.
So AI can surface this
information with speed
and it's basically like
thousands of analysts working
for you and surfacing information
which otherwise would not
come to the forefront, right.
Beyond this, AI also helps you
to basically act smarter, I would say.
Be it your mundane
day-to-day routine tasks
that you're automating,
or be it complex workflow simplification,
AI helps you to focus and
channelize the human energy
where it matters the most
in building relationships.
In building relationships
then also just the experience, right.
Beyond this, I would say not just tech,
but AI is a game changer, right.
So AI is a cultural shift, so
it's super important for us.
- It sounds like you've got a good balance
between where you're focusing
on colleague enablement,
but also customer engagement.
- Yep.
- Customer experiences.
And it's important when
organizations are thinking about it
from both sides of the house,
because it creates those more holistic,
rounded use cases
throughout the organization.
- That makes sense.
- Thanks, Amit.
All right, Hrushi.
- Oh.
- The Salesforce trust boundary.
Why is that a non-negotiable requirement?
- I'll start with a very serious note,
that when it comes to security
and compliance of our customers' data,
both Salesforce and AWS take them
as priority number one, right.
So enterprises basically trust us.
And when it comes to
like a trust boundary,
they want an absolute, whether
it is like a user prompt,
or the intermediary workflow
where the agentic AI workflow is trying
to process the data or
the final AI response.
All has to be done, or
none has to actually cross
that trusted boundary, right.
So together actually both,
I mean AWS and Salesforce,
designed and built a solution
that meets the data residency
and compliance requirements
for our customers globally,
across 22 regions.
And we're counting, I guess, right?
So 24 maybe, something like that.
But the key thing here
is that the customers,
wherever the customers operate from,
no matter in the world,
we are making sure that,
and we are assuring
that your data remains
within the trusted boundary
that you have established with Salesforce.
- So trust boundary
really in data residency
and ensuring the safety,
security, stability of that data.
- Yeah.
- But also,
as you start to provision
that data access to agents
is ensuring that you've
got that consistency,
particularly, I think about it in a world
where you start to think of agents
that are talking to other agents
and how to ensure that
same trust boundary across-
- Yeah, it's both.
I would say it's both north-south
and east-west, for example.
- Yep.
- Agent-to-agent or agent-to-models.
So you have to keep, make sure
that your customer's data
is secure and compliant.
- Right. Thank you.
Okay, one more for you.
- Oh yeah.
- And you've got the
cheat sheet right there.
So the integration, I'm not gonna...
You've got this.
How does the integration
with Amazon Bedrock
ensure compliance for our joint customers?
- So I'll start with first
Amazon Bedrock, right.
Amazon Bedrock provides
you the secure connectivity
to the frontier models like
Anthropic Cloud, Amazon Nova,
and others through a
technology called PrivateLink,
which makes the entire application
to talk to these models privately
within the private network of AWS, right.
And certainly, I mean,
like if you look at the Agentforce,
there are two modules
which we talked about,
the Prompt Builder as well
as the Reasoning Engine.
And these modules
typically use Agentforce.
If you look at these modules,
these are using the Amazon
Bedrock models, right.
Anthropic Claude for the Reasoning Engine.
And there is a bunch of
models within Amazon Bedrock,
like the Claude Haiku, Opus, Sonnet,
as well as Amazon Nova,
Nova Lite, Nova Pro.
They're used in the Prompt Builder.
If you have used Prompt Builder,
that will give you model optionality.
So depending on customer's preference,
Agentforce also supports a feature
called in-country inference
profile of Bedrock,
I would say, which restricts the data
to remain within the country
where you are doing inferencing
or you're running the agentic
AI applications, right.
So I would say the compliance
rests on these three pillars.
One is your secure
connectivity to the model.
Second is no data addressed.
The third is depending on
the customer preference,
they can pick and choose
the in-country inferencing
so that the data never
leaves the country boundary.
- Perfect. Like, I'd
love to do a quick poll
just to see how many of you
are Salesforce customers.
I would imagine that you
all are AWS customers,
or it might be easier to say
who in the crowd is not
a Salesforce customer?
Like, would this be news?
Is this something that
is coming as news to you
that, ah, there is a partnership?
Again, like, as a customer,
Salesforce didn't necessarily
do the greatest job
at the onset of talking
about how open, extensible,
adaptable the stack was.
And it took a bit of finally convincing
and getting time with
the reps to say, okay,
I didn't realize that there was,
we could choose a model, let
alone from a library of models,
through partnerships like this.
So like, this is pretty important
for those that are starting
to explore and understand
and really understanding
how Atlas Reasoning works,
where Atlas Reasoning is not the model,
it's the one that helps to choose
what is the right model fit for purpose
based on guardrails that
a customer establishes.
- Yeah, I would say it's a
true multi-tenant environment.
I mean, Agentforce to scale
to these multi-tenant
requirements of model optionality,
I mean, tool optionality and other things,
is really based on your own requirements.
I mean, these tenants have
given those requirements to us.
- Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. Amit, what are your primary drivers
that made you choose Anthropic on Bedrock?
On Agentforce?
There would've been a plethora of options.
- Yep.
- Why this combination?
- Yeah, I think we had
three primary drivers.
One is the data residency
and compliance in general.
This model ensures that the data stays
within the Salesforce
managed trust boundary
and it does not leave the trust boundary,
which is critical for organizations
with strict data compliance
requirements, like such as ours.
That's one.
Second driver is in general the security.
The security first architecture
from Claude, right.
So Claude is known for a constitutional AI
which emphasizes a lot on transparency,
on safety, and less hallucination risk.
This just gives another layer
of reliability index for us.
So that's driver number two.
And the third key driver is
meeting people where they are,
like for example, in
Salesforce, in Slack, right.
When deployed via Agentforce,
Claude actually runs on Salesforce infra,
which offers tight control
over the prompt execution
as well as the model behavior.
So those were our key drivers.
- Yeah. And there's a lot
of native integrations,
I think ultimately is what
you're wrapping it around,
is to say this is again how
the conversation had evolved
with a number of CIOs over
the course of the year
to say "No, no, no, no, Salesforce,
I'm gonna build, I'm a build shop."
To then recognizing, hang on a second,
what exactly do you think
that you're building
when you think about
all the individual tiles
that are necessary to
build agentic architecture?
To then, exactly what you're describing,
is this, you know, I really
wanna think of a partner
that's gonna have native integration,
someone that's gonna do the work for me.
Someone that I've already got the stack
that is constantly upgrading, updating
and agentifying the stack that I have
and building those partnerships.
And so all the more reason that
we really wanted to show up
to make sure that people really recognize
that we've got this Better Together story.
Now I know I've got more questions,
but I also wanna open it up to the crowd
because we can mix it up with the crowd
and then go back to the
questions that I've got.
Is there any questions that
we've got in the audience?
Yeah, okay. I dunno if
we've got a mic runner
or if you wanna just yell it out.
- [AUDIENCE 1] So on the
question of the multi-model
and the ability to choose your model.
- Yeah.
- [AUDIENCE 1] And I guess one
alternative here just means
that drop is-,
You know.
But what I don't understand,
and we've been kind of
looking a little bit
at the Salesforce and AI,
I'm trying to understand how, you know,
you've trained obviously
on something, right?
Whatever your existing
chat bots, everything are.
You've got data sitting, you know,
potentially in Salesforce.
But with making a choice
of a different model,
how is that model
operating against the data
that happens to be in your environment?
That I cannot-,
- So I'll take this up.
- Yeah.
- I mean, there are two types
of machine learning techniques here.
One is on the predictive models,
where the models are trained on your data,
which is in the Salesforce,
which you are training themselves
to give some predictions
or some kind of attritions
or some forecast, right.
That is a different aspect.
This is an agentic aspect.
In the agentic world, the
agent is a set of instructions,
or you could say user context
and the user query, right.
That orchestration is using a backend LLM
and the backend LLM
nowadays are so powerful
that you don't have to train
with the customer's data.
The LLMs can make and decide
based on the user query.
Let's say if someone
wants to take a time off
and they want to go and call
multiple tools for that,
so that that intelligence is in the model
that if a query comes
with this particular
agent instruction context,
then what tools I should be calling
to complete that particular task.
So that way, so to comment to your point,
the models which are behind the choices
which we are giving those models for,
those are the frontier models
which are quite intelligent
to come up with the workflow
given the right instruction,
right context.
That context that trusted data,
is what Salesforce is providing
as part of the in-flight
data to the model.
It's nothing to do with that
models are trained or not.
The thing which surely
is coming in the middle
are the trust layers, right.
So those models are trained
for specific toxic detection
or prompt injection.
Those are something it has
to be proprietary models.
But coming to your point,
the model optionality is
for those LLMs which are
giving these workflows.
- And the other thing that
I would say is, again,
that's coming in now is this idea
that you don't necessarily want
non-deterministic responses.
And so the ability to
have adaptive reasoning
and to be able to put in
parameters against those models
and against the instructions
where you want a finite
and definitive response versus
where you do want the LLM
to be able to reason, to think,
to consider what the
response option should be.
- [AUDIENCE 1] Let me expand a little bit.
- Yeah. And if folks, we're gonna...
Once the question's asked,
we'll just make sure
that everyone can hear.
If not, whoever's taking the answer can-
- [AUDIENCE 1] So if we
take the same concept
and talk about, you know, company data,
which helps you grow
and the truth of what the fact is
and not training the LLM by using that-,
but changing the choice of an LLM, right.
It could be on DeepSeek today
and it could be on
something else tomorrow.
So, the perception of changes,
the response of what you may have spent
building six months to a year, right,
now you're changing because
there's a better model,
cheaper model, it's performing well
and it's more data sufficient
than the other one is.
So you see some implemented
gains with that,
but there's a whole lot of
pipeline building worked on.
I think that's where we
got part of the same thing.
So this is where we,
interaction with Salesforce
could not wrap our head around to say,
how are you guys solving this?
And we never were able to have that-,
- Yeah. So I mean, by
the way, I mean we have-
- Sorry, sorry. Just quick question.
Did the folks on the
ends of the room hear it?
Okay. Can you-
- Got the question clearly?
- Yeah. Paraphrasing the question.
- Yeah. So the question was about, yeah,
when you're building
this agentic AI system,
a low-code, no-code environment, right,
how are you giving model optionality
without making big workflow
or pipeline changes?
Because every other model
has a different tone,
different way of responding
to a practical request, right.
So I mean I will not answer deep,
but there is a obsession on that.
ISV 309, please do come on that part.
But the thing is that it's all possible
because Salesforce thought this way ahead
and they built all these things so modular
and how having a different
or complete dedicated data
scientist team also helps a lot.
So this, I mean, combination
of these two building modularity,
bring some adapter level things,
which you can always
choose a target model,
even when you are
describing the agent actions
or descriptions, right.
If you make it AI-assisted,
that makes it easier
for the target model to interpret.
- All right, we'll go back to
some of the questions we have.
This is hopefully prompting you
to think of other
questions that you've got
within your own environment,
or just even broader questions
on what we talked about
in the earlier parts.
Okay, Pravin.
So, what is the most
tangible business impact
clients are seeing when they
implement Agentforce and AWS?
- Yeah, I think that's a good question,
but before I get to the exact response,
let me take a step back, right.
If we rewind back, like
say 12 to 18 months,
or maybe even like 8 to 12 months now,
- Yeah.
- Every AI and gen AI conversation
that was happening in like,
at least the conversations that
I was having with my clients
was essentially dominated
by like a DIY thinking,
like I want to do it myself, right.
- Absolutely.
- Like there was a,
there was lot of concern
around like security,
the compliance, and what
it is at risk, right.
Now, fast forward to today,
and if you think about it,
the landscape has changed drastically.
- Mm-hmm.
- Now the clients,
for them, the focus is more
on like obviously the cost,
but more important than
that is time to value.
Am I able to deliver
something to my stakeholders
which can really drive the value for them?
And with that context now,
a lot of clients have started
reevaluating what is feasible
and that reevaluation is leading to like,
hey, maybe there is-
Obviously we all knew,
like most folks in this room probably knew
that like doing it yourself
or like building everything
in-house is not the smartest
and never has been the
fastest way to get the value.
Because there are like these big players
like AWS and Amazon,
they're investing
heavily in the innovation
and coming up with all these frameworks,
interconnectivity and all those things.
And that makes a huge, huge difference.
So now there is a lot more
appetite for customers
to consider these like
very credible alternatives
that can drive the value
while also getting them,
like giving them the trust boundaries
and the frameworks that they can use
for scaling it at a pace
that can drive the value
for their business.
So where are we right now?
And what I'm seeing from my customers,
I would say like there are
like three or four things
that I would call out.
But number one theme is
about like time to value,
like faster time to value.
Like, am I able to deliver something
for my stakeholders which can
drive the immediate value?
And then the other thing
that is like the key thing
that is really originating
from all of this, is we started
with like a lot of like
point AI use cases, right.
I want to like-
We almost started like
thinking about like automation
in an agentic sense.
Like, what we used to do historically
as a automation of like
predict two things and then-
- RPA.
- That's what we call that
like agentic behavior.
But now it has become more like,
hey, I can't reason with it, right.
And I'm able to drive this value
and then I can do this at a scale
and at a speed which my teams
can like literally deploy
some of the AI-infused
capabilities or features
for a particular subset of the group
in days or weeks as
compared to months and years
that we had to do it.
That's the number one thing.
I think the second thing
that I would talk about
is operational efficiencies.
And I think this goes back
to that automation concept, right.
What has happened is like the mundane task
that we used to do and
those are repetitive tasks,
a lot of clients are like
essentially evolving towards like,
"Hey, these are the
things that I don't have
to have my resources
spend a lot of time on,
that I want to free up my
teams to do more strategic work
that can truly lead to
my like revenue growth."
And then the third thing that
I would say is around like
essentially cost optimization
of like doing some something like this
while also having the
flexibility and agility to scale
in different areas
where you want to scale.
So I would probably stop there with three.
There are a lot of other
things that I can talk about,
but those are like the top three themes
and the real benefits
that clients are seeing.
And there are clients who
are like really making
that like shift.
Like it's almost like a
tectonic shift now, right.
Where you are like very concerned
and you are like, "Hey,
should I do it or not?
What if it goes wrong?"
To a point where, "Hey, I want to do it.
Tell me how to do it the right way."
- And what you've talked
about is specifically like
from a use case perspective,
value, time to value,
efficiency, effectiveness,
experience, risk and control.
I think the partnership
brings so many more benefits
in the how you also do it.
Whether it is the fact that
you can now purchase Salesforce
through AWS marketplace.
It's not just the what
that you're implementing,
it's the how.
It's that there is an agent ecosystem,
or the AgentExchange,
where you've got agents
that you can now get that
are prebuilt through AWS
and through Salesforce together.
So it's a lot of the what
and the how, I'd say.
- Yeah, I would agree.
And I think like what,
and again, just going back
to like what has really
fueled this tectonic shift
is like these powerful
alliances and the partnership
and the interconnectivity
between different platforms.
Obviously we are talking
about Salesforce and AWS here.
But a similar thing is happening
with like Salesforce, Google Cloud.
Like there is Microsoft
doing their own thing.
So all these big platforms
have like come together
and they have forged these partnerships
because now everybody
is realizing that like,
hey, you can't really
do it all by yourself.
Doesn't matter how big you are,
whether you are Amazon,
Google, or like Apple,
like everybody is
realizing there is a need
to partner and collaborate
with each other.
- But here the partnership
that's most important
is Salesforce and AWS.
- For sure.
- That's the only one
we're talking about here.
- I agree.
- I have not heard about the others.
- I didn't hear anyone else.
I didn't hear any other
name in that response.
Amit, what governance
factors are important to you
when you're choosing to
deploy Agentforce on AWS?
- Yeah, so beyond just security,
there are three key
governance factors for us.
One is control, then compliance,
and then finally collaboration as well.
- The three Cs.
- Yeah, the three Cs is easier, right?
The three Cs.
So when it comes to compliance,
first of all, right.
So, A, yeah, this model
basically contains the traffic,
the LLM traffic within
the virtual private cloud
of Salesforce, right.
So the data is isolated,
it does not leave the private environment.
Couple it with data isolation
and the policy of Claude
to not retain any data,
it just helps us to know,
I mean, it just improves the
compliance portion for us
to know that this data is not being used
to train the model itself.
So it's added layer of
privacy, that's like one area.
Second is when it comes to control,
this model also gives us access
to the command center, right.
So the command center,
we can control and we can
also monitor agents realtime
for their performance, especially
their error rates, right,
or their escalation parts.
So this is super important for us.
Beyond this, the third aspect
is obviously collaboration.
We talked a bit about
agent-to-agent, right.
So agent collaboration is very real.
So an agent built on Agentforce
is expected to collaborate
with the agent built with
a totally different LLM
and totally different
ecosystem seamlessly.
So basically this model
checks all the boxes for us.
And you know, with the
use of A2A as well as,
you know, MCP protocol, this
absolutely helps us, right.
So it fits right well into
your enterprise strategy.
- Great, great.
And you talked about command center.
Going onto a small tangent for a moment,
like the command center,
you talked about it,
but like the importance of it, again,
as CIOs or tech leaders would
think about build versus buy,
these are the things that
they wouldn't think about
necessarily to say, "Am I
also gonna build the interface
that is gonna allow me to test,
if I'm building it from scratch,
that's gonna enable me
and allow me to test it,
or the interface that allows me to do..."
You know, I think about an agent.
So generative being a co-pilot,
something that's sitting on the side,
that's helping me type and
it helps me do something.
With agentic being like a
colleague, a virtual colleague
that's traversing the
halls of my organization.
Now, when I joined Salesforce,
I needed all the things
that this agent needs,
including the quarterly check-ins
that are happening post
one year in the job.
And that command center acts as a bit
of that quarterly check-in to say,
is this digital worker performing the way
that they were expected to perform?
- Absolutely.
- Underscoring that point.
It's very important.
I'll take one more
and then we'll open it
up to the crowd again.
Amit, back to you.
So what mechanisms are
you putting in place
to ensure control, auditability,
and prevent agent sprawl?
Agent sprawl. My goodness.
Like this feels like it's real.
I can only imagine that
you are being inundated
with every vendor under the sun going,
"Well, I've got an agent for you."
"No, no, no, I've got an agent for you."
So what do you do?
- Absolutely.
I think this is a really,
really important question,
especially for organizations
who are adopting autonomous
AI at this point.
And it's not an easy
answer to this, right.
So you need like a
multi-dimensional framework
to address this.
It's a combination of people, process,
and technology I would say.
When it comes to control, first of all,
to ensure that the agent
is indeed responding
or actioning within the boundaries
and with human intent
for those high priority
or really critical use cases.
Like for example,
processing a payment, right.
So you always need a human
in the loop initially, right,
until you gain a lot of confidence
with this particular framework, right.
So that is really, really important.
Beyond that, I think it's very important
to have like a stop switch
and a rollback mechanism for an agent.
If you see that it's either hallucinating,
or let's say it's drifting a bit, right.
So that is number two,
which is very important.
And you also have to
periodically just take a look
into what is the data this
agent is accessing, right?
And just reassess and kind of
build those guardrails around.
Just look at the security posture of this,
the risk classification of
this particular agent, right,
and all the action that it is
doing and keep on readjusting.
So that's very important
when it comes to control.
The second aspect is auditability.
I think we talked a
bit about auditability,
but really auditability is all about
we should be able to
trace everything back,
every action and decision
taken by the agent,
back all the way to its origin.
Either, you know, for
compliance purpose, that's one.
And second is if there is an incident,
the post-incident kind of analysis, right.
So we talked a bit about command center,
but then there is also testing center,
which is really, really important.
Beyond testing center,
enhanced audit logs.
Those are really, really important.
And we, at CrowdStrike, we
love to use this information,
process into a language
that we really understand,
so that we build those
additional layer of traceability
and detailed logging into
the tool of our liking.
So that's what we're doing.
- And again, all of this
out of the box as you had
invested in Agentforce.
- Obviously. It starts there.
We have all the information, and you know,
front-facing people are used
to different layers, right.
So we apply some layer, homegrown.
- Yeah.
- I think the third most important topic,
agent sprawl, right.
So again, This is a
rapidly evolving space.
So new terms are getting coined, right.
So agent sprawl is basically
proliferation of agent, right.
I know folks might know
here, but just reiterating,
proliferation of agents, but
agents which are unmanaged,
unsupervised, redundant, right.
The risk is, you know,
they might be security risk, number one.
Second is there might be
a lot of cost overruns
with this agent.
In order to avoid agent sprawl,
A, it's very important that
you build an agent registry.
So agent registry is very simple, right.
The concept is very simple, right.
Like what is the agent, right?
What is the scope of the agent?
What is the API scope of the agent?
What is the data scope of the agent?
What exactly is the risk classification
of this particular agent, right?
You need to have all this information.
Beyond that, once you build an agent,
you also need to outline
its complete life cycle,
right from the inception
of agent all the way up
to the decommissioning
or archival of the agent.
That's really, really important.
I mean these are couple of areas
which will help with the agent sprawl.
Beyond that, I think the agent
should also have some owners, right.
And ownership,
it's going to be a shared
responsibility, right?
At this point we are at a stage
wherein business is super
excited with the agentic world.
So they want access to the
agent, they wanna build.
Because they look at it, it's a prompt,
we can go and we can build something,
they want to do it, right?
- It's like RPA all over.
Blueprint them all over again.
- Yeah, exactly.
So I think it's very important
to draw certain boundaries initially
while you are on this journey,
wherein, you know, an agent
gets a business owner, right,
who is responsible for mainly its value,
and then agent also gets an IT owner,
who is responsible for
its maintenance, right.
I think it was a lot of talking,
but if you combine this
particular framework,
I think this may avoid the chaos
and help you run the agentic
enterprise successfully.
- Yeah, and I'll put in a shameless plug
on behalf of Salesforce,
is that this is exactly,
agent sprawl, what you just described,
what a lot of organizations are facing,
is exactly why we released
MuleSoft Agent Fabric.
- Yeah.
- It's a capability that enables all-
Oh, and we've got a question here.
We'll come to you after.
It's a capability that enables you
to be able to look at agents
that are not just Salesforce agents,
not just Agentforce, but
agents across the ecosystem,
and be able to put a layer of governance
and control over those
agents and that transparency.
- [AUDIENCE 2] Can you talk a little bit
about the orchestration layer,
using the same models to
manage your Agentforce?
And also, have you noticed
any emergent behaviors
from your system-,
- Okay, so orchestrational layer.
- I think you should go for it.
- So, and let me try to
repeat your question.
So you're saying that for
this agent orchestration,
are you using a separate LLM for it, or?
Yeah. Okay.
So I mean, kind of,
you could say that way,
because there is always,
there could be a headless
agent orchestration.
There could be one agent
which actually does
all the distribution to
the various other agents,
like a main agent orchestrator
sitting over the top of it.
So yes, wherever there is an agent module,
it has to be backed up by an LLM.
But it also has to have a good agent SDK,
like what Salesforce
has, its own agent graph
to come up with a very deterministic rule
that what exactly and how exactly
you're going to execute
this particular task.
Will it be calling multiple agents?
So that particular
combination of the right SDK
and the right LLM at every
other agent hierarchy,
multi-agent hierarchy is important.
So I would say, yeah.
To answer your question, yes,
there is a separate LLM for each of that
and those LLMs you could select
in the model optionality part.
- [AUDIENCE 2] Any emergent behaviors?
Is it always-,
- I think the emergent behavior
is it has to be really
bidirectional contact sharing
and a lot of things which
you need to really have
in A2A type of communication.
But I would say, yeah,
these are some of the
things which we are seeing
that's trending is more of like
agent-to-agent collaboration
is more towards how
those shared systems are,
or how the systems are shared together.
Like all the way from,
as Shibani mentioned
about observability,
governance, and other things.
So that's coming up now.
A lot of things are trending on that area
where governance, observability, identity,
these three things, I mean,
I think I would say are
key important roles.
- Oh, I wouldn't say that it's a behavior,
but it is an insight that has come.
I think when, like, just to back it up,
agentic or autonomous agents
have only existed for a year.
Like, it hasn't even
existed for a long time.
Like, it's as old as I am at Salesforce.
One of the patterns that has
emerged is I think early days
of agentic architecture,
autonomous agents,
there was this idea that
they're non-deterministic.
You know, you ask them a
question using these LLMs,
it'll give you a response.
You ask that question again
based on the context that it gains,
it might answer it slightly differently.
Well, one of the patterns that emerged
was actually there are times
where you don't want autonomous agents
to answer a question inconsistently.
And that's where adaptive
reasoning really came into play.
I think that I'd say maybe
what, three months ago,
three, four months ago,
where there was a greater
focus to say, no, no, no,
there are times when,
particularly in a highly
regulated industry,
there is no discretion in
how a question is answered.
It's black and white.
And so that is something
that's been really emerged,
or a pattern that I've seen that,
again, at Salesforce,
we've doubled down on that
to ensure that we've
got adaptive reasoning.
Meaning where you want
a consistent response,
you have the ability to hard code that in.
Where you want there to be some autonomy,
some thinking, like mimicking
the patterns of a human,
you can also enable that.
Okay. I'm gonna go on to
the next one that I've got.
Hrushi, how does the
combined power of Agentforce
and AWS help teams enforce
AI governance and guardrails?
And you could see that
governance and guardrails,
like this is a pretty big
theme that we've come out with
because this has been top of mind
for a number of the tech leaders
that all of us have been speaking with.
- So I think, Amit, you've
talked about a bit on that part.
Let me expand and show my perspective here
that AI governance, specifically
in the Agentforce stack,
is three integrated layers.
At the application layer,
It's an Agentforce trust
layer that comes into picture,
which does like data masking of PII data,
or prompt injection
detection, toxicity detection,
and also does a complete audit logging
at all Agentforce interaction,
adhering to all the automation
policy at every touch point,
including the agent
interoperability, right.
At the second layer, which
is basically the model layer.
So Agentforce using Anthropic
Claude Sonnet on Bedrock,
which is basically the
Anthropic Claude Model
is built on, as you mentioned,
the constitutional AI principle
to be helpful, harmless,
and honest by default.
So this actually helps
reduce the non-compliant
or toxic data even triggering
the Salesforce trust layer.
It gets activated before that, right.
So it gets a double protection.
And the third thing which
I will talk about is,
and in addition to that,
I would say Claude Sonnet
is also very strong
at instruction following, right.
That will help to do a kind
of a reliable, you know,
adherence to the organization policies.
Now the last layer, which
is the inferencing layer,
which is on the Bedrock,
and some of the trust models
runs on the Amazon SageMaker
in the private network of Salesforce.
That gives you like a complete
control about your data
not leaving the trust boundary.
More importantly, it also
gives you good traceability,
you know, good auditability,
and then I think good
visibility to this entire thing.
So entire governance stuff.
So I would say, just to summarize this,
it's a kind of a defense in depth approach
where our customers are getting,
I mean it's a complete visibility
and control on the AI
behavior with compliance,
audit logging, and all those
aspects available to them.
- Fabulous. Okay.
Pravin, back to you.
Top three steps Deloitte
is recommending to clients
to quickly and effectively
enhance AI data governance.
- Yeah, that's a great question
and I think it's also timely
because I think we have spoken
about the governance throughout this.
- Yeah.
- Amit covered it, part of it.
You mentioned some of it as well.
I think obviously for
all the right reasons,
every enterprise is trying to get
on the agentic enterprise journey.
And as they do it, obviously
for all the right reasons,
because there is like
a huge business impact
and the benefits that
could be gained from that.
At the same time, there is also need
to recognize the risk associated with it,
like if you don't do it right.
And some of the key things that obviously,
one of the very first things
that we did at Deloitte,
and this is almost like
18, 24 months back,
we defined what we called
a trustworthy AI framework
and that's what we take to our clients.
And obviously, if you
go to like deloitte.com
or like Google it, you'll find
like more details around it.
But the top three things that we recommend
to the clients based on the experiences,
number one is you need to define
and stand up your AI governance framework.
And there needs to be recognition
that AI governance is
no more like a security
or IT team's, whatever the word is.
That's not, it's not their
own ownership anymore.
You need to recognize AI
governance as a business problem
and it needs to be dealt
as a business problem.
And you need to solve
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah. And then you need
to have that top down buy in
from your leadership.
And that's one of the things that I like
when we work with Amit and
his team at CrowdStrike,
is there is this top level,
like right from CIO down,
there is a full buy in
on like we want to be on the agentic path,
we want to be an agentic enterprise
and we are invested in making
it happen the right way.
The second thing that I
would say is obviously
making sure you are defining
your overall data governance
and then make sure you create a visibility
of your data's lifecycle.
What that means is from the standpoint
of documenting all your data
sources, where the data exists,
what elements of that data you are using,
in what context would they
be used in your models,
how they enter into the
models and what happens
from like the time they
enter into the model
to getting into the outputs
that it generates, right.
And having that like
inventory of like your data
and creating that visibility
creates that trust with your stakeholders.
If you don't earn that trust upfront,
then you're gonna struggle
with like getting that adoption
from your business stakeholders
and even your customers.
And then I think the third,
maybe I will say four things,
but the third thing is more around like
making sure you are automating some
of your ongoing continuous monitoring
of what Amit was mentioning, right.
You cannot really rely on
somebody doing it periodically,
or some human trying to
do those audits for you.
You have to like automate
it, make it proactive,
and make sure you get
those proactive alerts.
And if something is going wrong,
you can define your
thresholds around like,
what is your hallucination threshold?
What is your error threshold?
And if those thresholds get breached,
the system is able to alert it
and you're able to course correct quickly.
And the last thing that I would say,
and this is going back to the
point that Amit was making
around like agent sprawl
and like documenting all
the agentic use cases.
One of the things that
we tell to the clients,
and we have had these
conversations with Amit as well,
is documenting your agentic use cases,
but also documenting all the
models that you are using
and make sure you're not creating,
another terminology that is
in the industry right now
is shadow AI.
- Yes.
- So you don't want to have the shadow AI.
Somebody wanted to do something
fancy because they liked it
and then nobody knows about it.
And if you don't know what
you are trying to protect,
you're not gonna protect it.
- Right.
- So that's the key.
So those are the four things
that I would say are the top things,
but obviously we can talk more.
Like this is one of the topics
where we can keep talking about.
- Well good.
- Yeah.
- And for those that are in the crowd,
if anyone does have a question,
we'll make sure we corner these gentlemen,
make sure we keep them behind
so you can ask any of the
questions that you've got.
Okay. One more, Amit.
You know, 'cause we're
getting down to the clock.
Tell us about your journey with Deloitte,
your path to success with
Agentforce, AWS, Deloitte.
Like just, this is an open,
more broader question.
- Absolutely. Yeah.
- Were you gonna do it on your own?
Did you decide to do it with a partner?
Like, how did you get to that?
- It's an exciting partnership
equilibrium, right.
So Deloitte has been a trusted
partner for CrowdStrike.
It's been years.
- Yeah.
- And Deloitte brings those
transformative mindset
right on the table, helps
us think outside of the box.
When you guys are starting
with your agentic journey,
you really have a few options.
Like, A, you can train your internal team,
that's number one.
Second is you can hire new talent, right.
Third is you work with a partner,
and the partner can really
give you a jumpstart
or rather slingshot, I would say,
because I mean, this is that era, right.
So they can bring in the
governance, leadership,
the execution acumen,
and that's where Deloitte comes in, right.
So we started our journey
on agentic pretty recently,
but looking at the output
that we have delivered the past quarter
and what comes ahead
in the next fiscal year
and coming quarters,
I'm really, really excited
about the roadmap, right.
Our strategy is very simple.
A is, yeah, we give those
tactical accelerators
to business folks, right.
One that they ask for, right.
And beyond that, we don't lose sight
to the wider agentic roadmap, right.
So we want our business teams
to really reimagine their
existing workflows as well
and really come up with
a very different mindset
and open mindset to agentify stuff, right.
And I think the path to success
is exactly the same, right.
Like, A, it's not only
delivering the strategic
like high efficiency gains
in like a quick turnaround
time, that's number one.
But at the same time also ensuring
that the wider processes are
reimagined via agentic lens.
- That's great.
And again, while agentic autonomous
might have only existed for one year,
partners like Deloitte really
bring the learned experiences
from even generative implementation,
AI broad implementation.
They see it across all of their clients.
They bring it to you.
- Absolutely.
- Great, thank you.
Any questions from the crowd before we?
Yes.
- [AUDIENCE 3] So what's
the role of the Cloud-,
And I know you have different-,
Sales Cloud and multiple
Salesforce Clouds.
- Yes.
- So what's the role of-
- So, I can...
Oh, look at this. We're
getting the curtains.
We've got six seconds
left for that question.
So Data 360, now Data
Cloud is called Data 360,
I'll do the very quick version of it.
You have a lot of data
lakes and warehouses.
Like, at my organization I
had Azure, I had Databricks,
Snowflake, but all of
those lakes and warehouses,
you couldn't actually extract data
to operationally leverage that data
to activate it across your ecosystem.
What Data 360 or Data Cloud ended up being
was a thin activation layer.
It wasn't like, it wasn't
warehouse, it had zero copy,
meaning the data stays within
those lakes and warehouses
through a zero copy partnership.
You could extract that
data, you could activate it,
you could use it, whether
it's for personalization,
whether it's for an
agent to perform actions,
and it would remain in the
respective lakes and warehouses.
The other clouds, those are just products.
I don't know why, we're
changing that as well.
Like Marketing Cloud is
just a suite of modules
that enable marketing
in a more efficient way.
Sales Cloud is your CRM.
Service Cloud is like workflows
and case management, as examples.
Okay, friends, they wanna
thank you all for sticking.
We got right to the end,
got a couple of questions
from the audience.
I wanna thank you all for today
and I wanna thank the crowd as well.
Really appreciate it.
Again, we'll be here for,
we'll be outside lingering.
- Thank you so much.
Thank you.
- Thank you.